nnps have just finished voting on
whether to uphold or reject the
emergencies act the results are in and
the government has won the day our chief
political correspondent david aiken
joins us from ottawa and david the
events over the weekend changed the tone
of the debate
well colleen opponents of the decision
to invoke the federal emergency act had
been saying all along that it was never
needed conservative and block quebecois
mps pointed to the fact that border
blockades were cleared without the
federal emergencies act and now that the
ottawa occupation has been cleared and
the capitol's downtown secured they
renewed their objections to the prime
minister's decision to invoke the
emergencies act so using the tactic of a
schoolyard bully he has decided to
implement the emergencies act so that he
can control manipulate dictate it's the
equivalent of awakening the kraken a
legislative leviathan that should only
be broken when in the most dire
situations i don't believe that the
government has met the test but the
prime minister insisted it was still
necessary noting that many of the
parliament hill trucks are now camped
nearby ready to return indeed this video
shot by global news monday afternoon at
a farm about halfway between montreal
and ottawa there were about 125 vehicles
many of which had been on parliament
hill these last few weeks and they're
now camped about a hundred kilometers
from ottawa on a private farm across
from a truck stop supplying them with
fuel food and supplies when the
situation is still
of people
pre-positioning people
being out there indicating that they are
ready
to blockade to continue their illegal
occupations to disrupt canadians lives
we feel that this measure
needs to remain in place it's a minority
government of course so the liberals
looked to the new democrats to support
them on this issue
and that's how the vote played out
liberals in the ndp voted to confirm the
emergencies act conservatives in the bq
voted against but that is not the end
the senate now begins debate on the very
same issue and it will vote later this
week and if the vote fails there then
that's it the powers in the emergency
act would be immediately revoked colleen
david aiken in ottawa david thank you